thank you
[Music]
please do not ruin this by looking at
what you're oh God eating because this
costs a lot of money really it's gonna
suck is this gonna burn my butthole oh
no it's not gonna burn it's that okay
it's not are you gonna feed us something
we're gonna vomit after no no it's just
a taste test of a new product okay it's
just chips there's no way it's not the
next it's spicy no it's fine something
that was made out of worms and bugs
down right now it's stinky toast do you
want to see his reaction I don't want to
close my eyes it's like a good reaction
first just eat it
Steve eat it it's just chips you eat it
first it's a talking straws just try it
just try it it's like ghost peppery [__]
here here you go let me go next there's
reaction wait I think you're talking can
I smell it do it in order just have a
chip
[Music]
this is like Cricket dust or something
it's not crazy it's just chips it smells
good yeah sure it's really good oh we're
supposed to smell it you can smell it
yeah you can do whatever you want just
don't we just can't see the cover do
whatever you want you don't look at the
bag okay this is actually edible yeah
yeah this isn't gonna [__] me up or give
me [__] I don't I don't think it will
okay go it is up
holy [__] [__] dude
what line holy [__] no waste these
[__] lines
I was like bro I was quivering I was
like if that makes Steve
it's gonna burn me dude
with me nah it's just a little chip it's
just a chip
it's pretty good right
it's like you guys were eating baby [__]
it's just chips
isn't it it tastes like a jalapeno chip
or like a do a pickle chip cool dusted
with like yeah yeah maybe I hate that
cool I know dude
you don't eat it eat it they're actually
really good don't [__] lie to me
see so many what the
[__]
why are you telling him doing so many
yeah
no reason is that
come on man hold
on
it's just chips right yeah is this like
someone's ashes in here or something
what that is weird it tastes like a chip
from Asia you know Asia has weird
flavors like green onions soy sauce lays
or some [__] oh yeah good tastes good
yeah try it out you eat it yeah you eat
one right now no it's human no it's not
human come on I'm starting to feel sick
I think it's in my head though
it tastes good
the Bart's got two different chips over
here
it just smells like barbecue sauce it
might just
make him eat it make him eat it it's not
the episode's not about me eating it
guys
he's next it's like barbecue sauce yeah
who is that jalapeno he's saying Barbie
oh what if it's [__] made out of
menstruation or something no no no no no
wait I'll I guarantee you why don't you
eat it it's not made of anything it's
like it's just chips it's just flavored
differently then why you gotta I gotta
describe that I try to [__] with this
one why don't you eat it
do you have a bag already
all right now that everyone's had one
pretty good though right objectively
if you're at a party yeah I would keep
grass yeah it tastes good actually so
what you guys just had onions there's a
company a new company in Lithuania and I
had to order these because they don't
sell them here yet
Lithuania they are how much did it cost
before the airline like 40 bucks for
this one bag oh [__] because I have to
wait I have to wait forever to get it
but what you guys just had
is the very first
dick flavored chips
[Laughter]
wait hang on let's [__] video dude
hey when we're all saying that it's good
then we like dictate I didn't know dick
tasted so good now I gotta suck all this
dick now now we're gay hey are we gay
Jazz
kind of good hey why is it jungle
edition dude what makes me jump
can I suck one of your dick I want more
dick flavor
why does Dish taste so good so this
company basically figured out a way to
simulate what a dick actually tastes
like in your mouth it's barbecue sauce I
wish my dick tastes like this yeah it
tasted it before only we had a [__]
sucker in a room that could confirm it
says yes for sex that's what yeah dude
wild taste yeah this company this
company makes a lot of difference Ryan
you have to eat some different flavors
of chips it was 40 bucks you have to eat
some too on camera all of us are gay
together it actually kind of tastes like
um beef noodle soup you know beef noodle
soup kind of tastes like that oh it does
it does kind of taste like beef hey Nick
does it say lithuy
this is potato chips dick flavor
rapeseed oil potatoes spices salt tomato
powder yeast extract say like dick
flavor yeah like they got a guy to like
hey Ryan's gotta eat it don't eat it but
I got a guy on a treadmill running they
collect his ball sweat and [__]
somehow turned it into got suction cups
in a hose that's not connected to just
as long you know what tastes more like
dick what [__] the Chinese fish
turkey
I'm talking about that [__] [__]
tastes like it honestly this European
dick it's just smoking wow see it
it's jungle edition all right dick
flavored Chas kettle chips it's only 18
plus okay wild taste no preservatives
all bodies taste good yes for sex
damn give this to a kid are you gonna
get are you gonna make them dick hungry
is that the idea you got to keep it 18
plus dude it says 55 yeah potatoes now
it's got the same thing
tastes really good though Lithuanian
dick sweat yeah natural flavoring that's
the natural flavoring is it how much is
it regularly I don't know because
um they they don't sell it here
um if you look up like Chaz chips
uh yeah it's it's only like I had to buy
that on I think eBay it says here pack
using protective gas oh they're like two
bucks oh damn forty dollars I like to
dig one better than I like this one yeah
so they have um I can't I can't get this
video Until Ryan eats as well so we're
all in the same page no I'm not gay
[Laughter]
I don't feel so disconnected is all get
connected even it goes there may be
traces of celery soy milk and smegma
store in a dry place at a room
temperature away from direct sound oh my
God there's dick in here they also have
pushy flavor too they have [__] flavor
as well why don't you get that 100 the
[__] flavor because it would have hog
the whole bag ah you're gay you're so
gay you know how much I love [__] he's
gay because he knew yeah kind of good
okay nice it's good right no it's not
bad it just tastes like barbecue chops
uh sauce chips you think if we lick it
like we'll just get flavor and not think
potato oh probably we also have um they
also have Bloody Mary flavor like a
cocktail that just tastes like V8 that
sounds good
yeah the V8 chips I'm glad you guys
didn't know what it was when you ate it
though and they all admitted it was
delicious the reveal was great what kind
of down I thought it was going to be set
us up dude yeah Bart took a whole
handful he took like a dick size amount
I don't like [__] around that's why
yeah so if you guys want to try these
it's jazzchips.com there's probably an
easier way to get it than what I did but
I needed it right away so it was gonna
be some Cricket dust [__] like Steve
said I would never make you guys do that
no but you'd give us dick flavor yeah
yeah because that's the stone start away
it's just don't throw away what you're
used to yeah
but yeah shout out to Ian abando for
suggesting that I make you guys do this
oh thank you thanks Ian
hey you I don't like how you just made
us gay like that but whatever on the
internet whatever Ian Ian is actually
like a cool guy we should probably have
on the show sometimes you went too far
he's the director of this show called
Invincible it's like an animated no way
yeah oh no he's the director he watches
this show and was like yo you should get
these guys [__]
[__] you're way too smart for the
show dude yeah stop watching move on bro
you come to this show to tank baby
not bad right yeah it's really good it
did taste Asian right
did you have that at like Spencer's or
something I feel like it would end up at
Spencer's in onion with seaweed I
believe you yeah there is some seaweed
flavor to that
which might be what dick tastes like a
little bit it might be yeah because
we'll never fully know right we should
have done this with some like chicks
here
and then we'd actually get some like you
know yeah yeah some actual feedback all
of us are like yeah I think so so that's
about right I wish they made it taste
like bleach or something
you know why don't you get like a like a
it's like a nacho flavored chip but it
doesn't taste like nachos it never does
I don't think they can you can't nail
nachos like that salsa verde is pretty
good it's very good
which one salsa for the green Doritos
that was pretty good oh the green ones
are good should we try [__] ones next
yep yeah we should trip it'll be here in
four to six weeks
it literally comes from Lithuania
favorite do you have a favorite chip
like this is your [__] those little roll
ones the the um Pringles you know that
to read um what the [__] is it flavor
twist the flavor twist but like the the
lemon chili one the uh Takis no no no
those are great too but it's similar to
Takis but it's like Doritos oh I think
you know we're talking about [__]
good dude they're [__] good my hands
down favorite I mean I like a lot of
them
out to my two is Cool Ranch and the
Flaming Hot Cheetos I'll go double extra
flaming hot Cheetos the black bag
flaming hot cheetos are pretty good but
I like uh salt vinegar Pringles salt
vinegar so good that's good too actually
because kettle chips is cool but
Pringles they melt in your mouth bro
Pringles are banging salt vinegar lays
is my number one favorite oh because
it's a softer chip kettle chips are good
but they got a bite sometimes it rips
your mouth my favorite snack of all time
is the Snyder's honey mustard pretzels
those are so good I just had for the
first time those are so good what's that
the ones that come in the buckets
crunchy it's big it's my favorite snack
of all it's so good honey mustard it's
oh it's not even thick flavored chips
climbing the charts I'll tell you that
yeah thanks I'm a [__] Lover now thank
you guys for trying it uh Nick you want
to finish first thank you
laughs
[Music]